he has been a sta critic of President
Alberto Fernandez's handling of the
economy but on Tuesday farri elected
president Javier M visited Fernandez at
the official residence to begin
discussing the
transition the journey was televised on
National Television M met with Fernandez
for a few hours it was supposed to bring
confidence to a country that many say
has jumped into the unknown kavier m is
using this hotel as his headquarters
until he takes off on December 10th
there's lots of uncertainty about how
he's going to carry out the radical
reforms to transform Argentina's economy
but there's also lots of questions about
how to keep the economy operating during
the
transition Argentina's economy is
struggling with soaring inflation the
peso is tied to the US dollar there are
several exchange rates and the
government imposes strict currency
controls mle has promised to lift those
controls shut down the central bank and
dollarized the economy on Tuesday
Argentina's peso lost 10% in the
parallel markets and many fear it could
get worse in the leadup to inauguration
day I'm quite uncertain and Afraid the
truth is that this man did not offer
anything he was not very clear with his
proposals well he was clear with his
proposals but not in the way he wants to
implement
them economists say he will have to
build alliances in in order to carry out
his reforms how can you push that
through a system where he only has I
mean he has no Governors out of our 24
Governors he has zero he has 38
congressmen and he has seven Senators so
he has to find uh some kind of
Partners M won with over 55% of the
votes a figure that gives legitimacy to
carry out reforms many are desperate for
economic stability in Argentina a
country where INF
has been a problem for far too
long Al
buenos make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer